hi Jessica welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I have an income problem
and I'm not sure how to tackle it a few
weeks ago I read the Total Money
Makeover after getting a small
inheritance and I was able to pay off
all my debt except for my student loans
and including the debt that I used to
set up my business I've been working to
set it up for the last year and it's
been open for about six months problem
is it's a law firm and I have two
hundred and sixteen thousand dollars in
student debt I have essentially three
part-time jobs they're all acting like
full-time jobs I have my law firm I also
have a ministry that I've been very
successful at and that I'm looking at
creating more low-hanging fruit income
from but I also have some health issues
including infertility that we're dealing
with and I've just been feeling a lot of
anxiety about this debt now and knowing
that it's probably going to be another
year and a half at least until I'm
getting a chanak significant income from
my law firm or from my ministry work
probably a combination of both so I've
been thinking hard about just giving up
and getting a Jo B but I'm afraid
because of my health issues or if I hope
that we would get pregnant I don't want
to do that to someone who just just
hired me so feeling a lot of anxiety and
I'm not sure whether to stay the course
with what I've been building which does
seem to be starting to pay off dividends
knowing that it's going to slow me down
you're kind of an underachiever aren't
you have you ever seen a project you
didn't tackle kid oh wow you go for it
ah all right so how much does your
husband make a 60,000 he's a teacher
okay and the law firm you think is going
to break even for a year I
a lot of expenses there because I run
out from my kitchen table and the
Internet
and so it doesn't take more than like I
would say I will break even with ten
thousand dollars in income mm-hmm
everything about that should be gravy
same with my ministry work I've been
doing it for several years and my blog
gets twenty five thousand hits a month
so I've been thinking of slowing down my
referral tents like going out and doing
that sort of work so that I can write a
book so I can get my first book done and
my husband supporting me in all of these
but he's also very concerned about the
$200,000 I'm the risk taker of the
family and I like these new products and
I believe that risk often pays off and
as with many of these things I've done
it has paid off but he's very none of us
paid off with money yes not yet paid all
paid off in that sense it is not paid
off the ministry is fruitful the law
degrees not making you any money but
it's not costing you any money today but
so fruitful are paid off is not you know
that completely there so just in the
three minutes that we've known each
other
I you sound like someone that needs to
narrow your focus and quit taking on new
projects you are talented you are bright
you are articulate there is a lot of
things you can do you will do none of
them if you try to do too many of them
at once I thought it was narrowing it
they're going down to this very well no
then your son write your book a minute
ago you remember that part where you
were writing a book I remember that well
that's the slowing for what I think our
little hanging fruits with I have a much
more solid base within the ministry than
I do with say the law firm which I've
only got three clients yeah
where have you ever worked for a law
firm yes I worked for um so
practitioners okay for a while and what
did you make there I did not work with
one sense leaving Law School I haven't
practiced since leaving law school
because of the job market I wasn't a
think-tank for a while but they lost the
grant that fund in my position and I got
laid off which is kind of how I fell
into this
I mean you could in a sense if you
wanted to call the Law Firm parking your
law license and not really doing
anything much with it and focusing
exclusively on the ministry but ministry
aspects whatever you're doing there has
got to create some income mm-hmm and
because your husband's right that you
spent $200,000 on this law degree and
now you want to do ministry and write
books and so you've got to make that
work if you're gonna go that way that's
a reasonable request on his part oh and
that's that's not really a request on
his part but you said he was stressed so
I'm calling that a request that's what's
weird is he's not requesting that I know
but it's you know what's thinkin that we
address this situation and who knows
infertility could be tied in to all the
stress with all these 14 different
things going on at once here - exactly
he's encouraging me to continue doing
the free work while simultaneously
saying that this is stressful and also
making me feel that it's my
responsibility alone which is it is not
your ability alone but he's only making
60,000 so and you live in New York so
your chances of having a lot of surplus
to throw at 200 without you kicking in
some income is there mm-hmm what would I
tell you to do if you were my daughter I
would give the ministry a timeframe to
start making some serious cash if it
does not I would Park it mm-hmm and that
would be a six months we're gonna go
full force on that thing if it doesn't
work I'm gonna go get a job in the law
firm and I'm gonna make a hundred a
hundred and a half a year and I'm gonna
get these debts paid off and that's
gonna free me up to move on if I can't
get the ministry really cooking and
making some money pretty quick okay and
if you want to park the
you're you know your law license in the
sense of not utilizing it much and not
taking on new clients and that kind of
thing while you're doing that that'd be
a suggestion I'm going to be completely
focused and turn this book into a book
deal and get them to write you have me
into our check as an advance or whatever
if you've got a book that's that hot
you've got a pretty good base of
followers there on your blog to at least
begin the idea of doing a book proposal
for some some legitimate publishers
you've got a platform to launch a book
from at least a small one and you know
you can begin to start up your tribe and
look at what those three or four things
and the low-hanging fruit that you can
do are that monetize the service that
you're offering through this ministry
and give yourself some period of time I
don't think I'd go a whole lot longer
than six months I want to just making
some money and and I really Park
everything else in your life sideline
everything else until you get that
moving or then after six months if it's
not moving park yet and let's go make
some money
for a period of time here until babies
come and student loans are gone